[Musique]
il
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau vais y t l'émission nous
découvrent des personnalités yvelinoise
alors je me trouve en compagnie de
frédéric dreyer bonjour vous êtes le
responsable des animations à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet et vous venez
d'être élu yvelinois de l'année 2021
alors par les lecteurs de toutes les
nouvelles de versailles c'est ça il y
avait quand même trente candidats en
lice dont le christophe bertrand
chocolatier versailles et ou encore
guillaume chaîne judokas qui décroché
l'or aux jo en équipe un sentiment
d'être sur scène oui c'était il y avait
très belle personne de très très beaux
projets effectivement un champion du
monde un champion olympique de très
belles entreprises solidaires et voilà
le projet qui a été retenu tous les
projets sont intéressants donc j'ai la
chance de finir premier parce que j'ai
effectivement pu profiter d'un réseau de
personnes qui ont accompagné ce projet
depuis trois ans donc il fait que du cui
voilà moi quand je leur ai parlé du
projet ils ont voté ont relayé
l'information qui fait que du coup j'ai
effectivement fini premier mais bravo à
tout ça en l'air les applaudit
alors on le rappelle vous parler de
projet vous vous avez été nominé qu'un
vous avez créé en 2021 un jardin
sensoriel à parcourir à pied lui là où
nous nous trouvons un dess qui se trouve
juste derrière nous d'ailleurs moi même
j'avais testé ce parcours pieds nus ou
d'ailleurs vous pouvez retrouver le
reportage sur le site internet tv 78
points comme alors il s'appelle le
jardin de montorgueil et vous disiez il
ya quelques mois que c'était le plus
important projet mené depuis 25 ans au
sein de la ferme pédagogique
pourquoi il ya eu effectivement
l'ouverture de la ferme pédagogique à
peu près 25 ans qui fonctionne plutôt
bien quand tout va bien mais les deux
années ont été un peu compliqué mais
c'est pas loin de cent mille vies ces
cent mille visiteurs qui viennent tout
au long de l'année des scolaires des
touristes effectivement donc voilà les
projets fonctionnent plutôt bien sûr la
ferme avec des événements qui sont
reconduits qui sont modifiés voilà
effectivement ce lieu a permis
finalement d'élargir la ferme
pédagogique est de faire découvrir un
espace vraiment différent du monde
agricole plus sur le côté écosystèmes et
naturel et alors est ce que vous pouvez
peut-être me décrire
ce parcours pieds nus et finalement quel
était le but donc c'est un ça fait
partie de finalement de l'ensemble de la
bergerie à la bergerie avant d'être
nationale était impérial et avant au
royal louis saez en 1786 achète ce
domaine pour faire une ferme
expérimentale travailler à la fois sur
le côté animal et végétal est
effectivement là où on se trouve c'était
le terrain d'acclimatation des deux
plantations exotiques et avec l'arrivée
des mérinos en 1786 finalement le côté
végétal a été abandonnée c'est pour ça
que ce lieu dans mes recherches
historiques j'étais obligé de faire ce
genre de richesses et c'était très
enrichissant ça fait à peu près 150 ans
que le lieu n'est plus utilisé et moi je
m'en suis un peu gelé un peu utilisé
dans le cadre d'animations scolaires et
c'est effectivement en 2019 en allant
découvrir un exploitant en belgique que
l'idée m'est venue de
deux le des boisés de leur travail et
d'ouvrir cet espace en y installant un
parcours pieds nus alors justement le
jardin et son parcours pieds nus là sont
fermés jusqu'au mois d'avril 2002 et
rouvre en 2022 en avril 2000 22 mai
alors on pourrait bien sûr le projet sa
force si c'était d'avoir associé des
travailleurs handicapés les ath
boulanger notamment quand ils ont
participé à la création du jardin c'est
vrai qu'en 2019 quand j'ai présenté le
projet à ma direction suite à mon voyage
d'étude en belgique mon directeur madiba
c'est un super projet mais la condition
sinequanone c'est de trouver quelqu'un
pour faire la gestion paysagère
l'entretien la tombe des gazons la
gestion des arbres donc j'ai simple
voilà étant
en connaissance avec un éducateur avec
qui on pratiquer le même sport je lui ai
proposé ce projet est effectivement il
est éducateur technique spécialisé
espaces verts jardinage maraîchage je
vais proposer le projet est
effectivement il s'est associé tout
laisse donc qui m'a beaucoup aidé pour
la mise en place du projet pendant un an
un an et demi et là il vient quasiment
une fois par semaine peut-être moins en
ce moment puisque c'est l'hiver mais il
reviendra dès le printemps pour pour
faire l'entretien effectivement sans cet
entretien forcément les arbres ont
repoussé r va repartir en friche et
c'est très important d'avoir ce groupe
de personnes en situation de handicap et
ça les fait aussi travailler dans un
milieu dans un milieu ordinaire alors là
justement on se trouva donc au coeur du
jardin de mon orgueil et vous proposez
aussi un théâtre de verdure d'ailleurs
je crois qu'on est dessus hein c'est ça
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer à
quoi ça sert il y avait effectivement
cette petite cuvette et on se dit dès le
départ que c'était l'endroit idéal pour
faire ce théâtre de verdure et donc du
coup voilà l'idée c'est de proposer une
scène et d'avoir la possibilité
d'accueillir jusqu'à 100 personnes à
l'extérieur c'est vrai que ça tombe bien
avec la crise sanitaire qu'on ait envie
qu'on est en train de jesper de terminer
les gens ont envie je pense de se
retrouver dehors donc on a imaginé tout
un programme
tout au long de l'année c'est vraiment
un lieu que j'ai baptisé le tiers lieux
un peu local qui permettra à tous les
rambos lite un les associations qui
l'ont découvert là du coup lors de son
ouverture l'année dernière qui ont
vraiment apprécié et de se dire de
malades de leur donner la possibilité de
faire des représentations musicales
théâtrales de faire des conférences que
ça soit finalement un complément de ce
qui est déjà proposée à la bergerie et
pour l'instant les retours sont très
positifs très bien on va maintenant
parler un peu de votre parcours à vous
cela fait 25 ans que vous êtes employé à
la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
vous êtes arrivé ici eh bien j'avais le
projet de monter en une ferme
pédagogique chez moi dans le nord deux
dans le nord de la france et on m'a dit
qu'il fallait vider en se former à la
bergerie qui étaient missionnés par le
ministère de l'agriculture pour
justement permettre à tous les les
initiateurs de créer leur ferme
pédagogique je me suis formé je me suis
vite rendu compte que n'ayant que le
côté éducatif et pédagogique j aurais eu
forcément des difficultés à en vivre
parce qu'il faut avant tout être éleveur
élever des animaux pour faire une
production et faire de la pédagogie en
plus moi y'a que le côté pédagogique qui
m'intéressent me sens pas l'âme d'un
éleveur et finalement j'ai découvert ici
des gens sympathiques et un projet qui
démarre il ya 25 ans la ferme était
vraiment toute nouvelle le côté
pédagogique était vraiment tout nouveau
ça commencé dans les années 80 95 et je
rêve en 87 voiliers et donc du coup je
suis resté là et de fil en aiguille j'ai
proposé un certain nombre de choses j'ai
gravi un peu les échelons et puis ça
fait à peu près dix ans que maintenant
je gère je gère l'équipe l'équipe
d'animation avec toujours c'est assez
facile entre guillemets on va dire on
est dans un bassin de population il ya
tellement de monde où les gens sont
quand même assez déconnecté du côté
nature et campagne de proposer des
choses qui m'intéresse et qui intéresse
qui intéresse le public est justement
vous à paris en 2000 vous avez donc
monté cette équipe d'animation donc
d'être maintenant responsables
commencent avait fait finalement pour
faire grandir la ferme la bergerie
nationale
il ya eu beaucoup il ya eu beaucoup de
réflexion on n'a pas toujours tout
réussi et on s'est rendu compte que je
prends l'exemple des vacances c'est vrai
que c'est sur l'exemple que je donne on
a on a essayé de thématiser les vacances
ou en mettant en avant le projet
d'établissement de la bergerie qui est
l'agro écologie l'agriculture durable
tout ça mais les gens ont pas forcément
accrocher ce qu'ils avaient envie quand
il venait à la bergerie c'est de passer
du bon temps c'est s'amuser le côté
ludique sortir les enfants donc
finalement on a mis ça en avant tout en
ayant toujours l'idée l'objectif de
faire passer des messages derrière
derrière côté ludique voilà c'est
finalement l' approche pédagogique qui
est différente mais derrière le message
est toujours le même c'est d'expliquer
ce que c'est que l'agro écologie
l'agriculture durable la nature et le
respect de l'environnement si je vous en
parle et il est 78 venu aussi quelques
fois durant les nombreuses animations
que vous organisez il en a pendant
quasiment chaque vacances scolaires des
animations ça doit être un sacré travail
où tu imagines c'est vrai que du coup
localement jeu par expérience je sais
qu'il ya finalement très peu de
structures qui proposent des animations
thématiques comme ça pour chaque
vacances et je pense que c'est vraiment
la force de l'équipe d'animation des
animateurs et de la bergerie de proposer
des choses thématique ludique mais
toujours avec cet objectif d'expliquer
ce que c'est que le projet
d'établissement et je vois là on vient
de passer les vacances de la toussaint
on a eu sept mille personnes les
vacances de noël sont un peu plus calmes
effet halloween lancé ce à dire qu un
mixte entre sait pas que sorcier s'est
expliquée finalement des choses
scientifique mais qui peuvent penser
qu'ils peuvent sembler être magique
alors que tout s'explique de façon
scientifique ces voix là c'est un peu le
principe ne sait pas que sorcier nous
avec le côté un peu harry potter
effectivement est pareil à noël aussi
oui des animations noël autant les
premières années le père noël
on l'avait invité à venir que le 24
maintenant voilà on essaye de le faire
venir quasiment tout le mois de décembre
avec des éliminations et plein de plein
de festivités avec une belle crèche ce
sont aussi de nombreuses yvelinois
enfants qui viennent chaque année à la
fin vous savez à peu près combien de
visiteurs maintenant il ya désormais oui
bah justement là on est en début d'année
que ce soit à rambouillet territoire au
département ils m'ont demandé de faire
un petit un petit bilan de l'année donc
on a eu l'année dernière 79000 de 89
visiteurs donc beaucoup plus que l'année
précédente on a été beaucoup plus fermé
je trouve que par rapport à quand même
des mois où on a été fermée c'est une
belle fait une belle fréquentation voilà
il ya on a vécu des mois difficiles en
début d'année 2021 mais c'est vrai que
le deuxième semestre et la fin du
premier tout le monde a voulu venir à la
bergerie de pouvoir ressortir et on a
essayer de contenter à la fois
l'événementiel mais aussi beaucoup les
écoles qui ont finalement essayé de
reporter et on a eu des mois hyper
chargé mais bon c'était très difficile
mais en tout cas les on a pu contenter
le plus de visiteurs possible parce que
en 2020 vous avez été peut-être fermer à
l'entente on a eu à peine cinquante
mille visiteurs voyez donc on a réussi
a bien remonté la pente et on espère que
2022 ça sera une année complète oui et
en plus je crois bien que en 2011 vous
avez organisé un drive fait remixer oui
oui bah du coup comme on a été fermée
qu'il fallait se remettent aussi en
cause on a ouvert on a ouvert un dry
fermer un fermier qui a permis à du coup
aux gens de pouvoir accéder à une bonne
alimentation locale et est aussi
d'imaginer finalement une valorisation
un peu différente de nos produits parce
qu'on travaille beaucoup avec les
collectivités territoriales ou les
grandes entreprises et il fallait du
coup comme tout était fermé les collèges
les lycées pas mal d'entreprises le
télétravail tout ça finalement les
produits fallait les vendre plus sur
site et on a développé une vente très
proche de rambouillet et surtout dans la
boutique de la bergerie du mérinos café
maintenant on est en début de 22 on
espère que ça ira mieux alors on
aimerait savoir puisque vous êtes le
responsable des animations quelles
animations seront au programme cette
année à venir là on travaille sur les
prochaines vacances c'est une enquête à
la ferme donc il ya toujours une petite
énigme à résoudre
sur sur un voleur qui est passé à la
bergerie pour voler les secrets de la
bergerie delà de la bonne laine des
produits laitiers de la traction animale
on voit là il faut les enfants pourront
mener une petite enquête c'est un peu
cheap escape game où il faut mener l
enquête après mia toutes les vacances
qui défie les skis et un le moment
important dans les moments importants il
faut y aller doucement c'est pour les
vacances les le mois de juin où on va
développer ici dans le jardin de
montorgueil les jeudis les jeudis au
jardin une ambiance un peu guinguette
bal apéro avec la possibilité de se
restaurer de passer des bons moments
d'apprendre à danser de de pouvoir se
rencontrer dans l'idée de préparer
l'événement début début juillet qui le
festival de la bergerie pour la
rénovation du patrimoine historique très
bien et va on espère on sera là
pour voir ça merci beaucoup
merci et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi et à très bientôt sur tv5 118
[Musique]